dans la 1ère circonscription des
yvelines florence imbert fait partie des
14 candidats qui se présentent pour
obtenir un siège à l'assemblée nationale
cet enseignant de 50 ans qui habite à
versailles sera la représentante du
mouvement demain en commun une femme
politique qui nous présente ces trois
axes de campagne au micro de michael et
me d'euros
je pense qu'il y a un aspect très
important devant programme qui est les
droits des femmes
je pense qu'il est indispensable qu'il y
ait une parité absolue dans tous les
domaines politique et économique
deuxième axe l'écologie et la
l'appropriation par les habitants de
leur patrimoine naturel donc la création
l'entretien des espaces verts co gérer
et partager le troisième axe est un axe
sociétale alors je pense qu'il est très
important que les français les
françaises et les français se
réapproprient la vie politique et se met
à participer activement à des projets
citoyens